la suite de notre feuilleton maintenant
je vous rappelle que nous vivons une
campagne de recrutement très
particulière puisqu'il s'agit
d'embaucher mille cinq cents saisonniers
pour le parc astérix
la date d'ouverture approche et à un
mois du spectacle nous retrouvons
caroline la chanteuse sosie de madonna
et les cascadeurs qui s'entraînent s'il
vous plaît
le texte bien clair ça va être drôle ça
va être entendu là il n'aura fallu à
jean-pierre que quatre semaines pour
donner à ces jeunes recrues l'apparence
devrait mousquetaires
ap
stop stop on va reprendre la course ici
on ne manque qu'une rigoureux tout est
réglé au millimètre près réveillez vous
un peu là ce qu'on a beaucoup appris
c'est l'action pour le spectacle en fait
mélangez l'action avec le texte se fait
pas n'importe comment et première fois
quand on ne faisait rien qu'à 2 qu'on
allait un peu la halle fait plus parler
en gt britannique car il ne sait
toujours pas si elle sera falbala ou pas
elles rencontrent aujourd'hui
jean-françois le metteur en scène a
préservé revue à l'audition je me suis
dit que ce serait très bien qu'on écrive
quelques choses pourront ou ça va être
chanté et dansé tous les soirs quand
est-ce qu'on avait démarré les
répétitions
donc on commence lundi 27 d'accord on
voulait qu'elle est entre 9h30 et 18h à
peu près d'accord ça vous embête si on
va à la costume gris prendre les
mensurations pour costume aller la
costume gris du parc c'est le passage
obligé pour tous les comédiens qui vont
animer le village gaulois
donc tu me dire combien
35 du mali combien faudra encore 24 et
carrure
vous savez ce que je vais porter ou ça
ne s'est pas encore tout à fait trop
faible si carrie ignore encore tout de
son rôle d'autres ont fait un saut de
plus dans le spectacle salto arrière
ils font déjà des figures à 4 verizon en
fait il son cv le plus artistique que
notre grille mais ce que nous on vient
des sports de combat donc on s'habitue à
se prendre des coups et sur cette
monnaie
la formation de cascadeur alors que eux
là il ya un gym il ya un gymnaste
danseurs après les alcools et bien voilà
par nos médias
c'est plus
ce artistique une fois c'est le côté en
bois les cascadeurs mousquetaires
devront pourtant bientôt savoir eux
aussi croiser les élastiques comme il
croise le fer avec peu de répète je
trouve qu'il ya un très bon niveau
d'exercice
d'autant plus que là que les conditions
ici de temps et de de son terrible pour
nous c'est plus la ressent qui sont
là-haut sanglant la plupart du temps
resté dix heures et des heures à zéro
degré
toute la journée ils font preuve de
courage et de bonne humeur on peut aller
on récupère aller
allez allez allez c'est bien et auquel
viennent tout de suite et milliards en
récupère nouveau ils ont une bonne
équipe sympathique aidons à leur permet
de mesurer toutes les souffrances qu'on
leur fait subir chaque année le parc
forme une nouvelle génération de
cascadeurs s'il passe le cap de la
première saison ils finiront par être
surnommés les irréductibles
engagez-vous par toutatis un feuilleton
signé stéphane despinoy francis forget à
lundi bat nicolas bertolo la suite bien
sûr demain